le soleil il procure on le sait une
énergie gratuite et écologique
à condition d'avoir les infrastructures
nécessaires si vous êtes équipé de
panneaux photovoltaïques
vous pouvez vendre à des opérateurs
votre propre production d'électricité
reportage à ballancourt sur essonne
gilles marine et valérie lucas
agriculteurs exploitants 350 hectares
dans l'essonne frédéric boucher avait
besoin d'un nouveau hangar le bâtiment
72 mètres de longueur en impose
le plus surprenant c'est le toit 544
panneaux photovoltaïques sur 1000 mètres
carrés qui produit de l'électricité
revendue à edf
est-ce que vous connaissiez l'énergie
photovoltaïque avant de faire ça non du
tout c'est grâce à un copain qui va qui
va parler de ça et puis j'ai fouiné sur
internet pour regarder à quoi ça
ressemblait il a très vite appris son
installation l'une des plus grandes en
france la production permet d'alimenter
simultanément 50 maisons individuelles
en éclairage
l'électricité est uniquement destiné à
la vente les panneaux reliés au réseau
edf
ici comme dans toute la france
l'ensoleillement est suffisant ce
panneau photovoltaïque c'est pas pour
chauffer c'est pour faire des facilités
il faut pas forcément se retrouver dans
le sud pour faire des tris site et ça
marche dans le nord de l'allemagne donc
il ya trop de raisons s'arrange pas au
sud de paris pour soutenir les énergies
renouvelables et df achète le
kilowattheure un tarif élevé 57 centimes
d'euros garanti sur 20 ans le toit
devrait ainsi rapporter de quoi
rembourser l'investissement total un
million d'euros panneaux et hangars en
17 ans bonne affaire d'ailleurs et df
croule sous les demandes
nous avons enregistré à peu près 500
demandes en 2005 sept mille en 2007 et
nous estimons à peu près avoir à traiter
20 mille demandes en 2008 ce qui fait un
accroissement relativement important et
ce n'est qu'un début la prévision pour
2011 est de 60 mille dossiers et
d'élèves s'organisent
mais les candidats à la production
d'électricité devront se montrer
patients